so I need your advice today or basically
I just want to know whether you were
interested in a 2020 david pakman show
calendar if you are sort of new to the
show in the last year and a half you may
not know that starting back and I
believe 2014 we have done yearly David
Pakman show
wall calendars and there's always a
theme
sometimes it's hatred mail banners
submitted by the audience we've
previously done political and show
related comic strips we've done a lot of
different things and we skip the
calendar last year we didn't do a 20-19
calendar at the end of 2018 quite simply
because we were just way too busy with
the new studio technical changes and a
bunch of other things and I've started
getting emails because it is getting to
be that time of year do we want or do we
plan to do one in 2020 so my question to
you is should we do a 2012 at 20
calendar I already spoke to Matt's track
pine about doing the art which would be
comics he's been doing some really great
comics which we've posted to our social
media platforms like the one that we're
showing our video and television
audience right now all related to the
show and two things going on with the
show and politics and independent media
the quality of this stuff is really
really good he is conceivably up for
doing 12 images for the 12 months of
2020 with a cover but really it's a
question of how many will we sell and
the way that we should do this is if you
would be buying a calendar and we
usually do it two ways you can just buy
a calendar on our website or you can get
a new yearly membership and you get the
calendar for free those are the two ways
that we do it how many people will buy
one so if you would be interested in a
calendar please get in touch by email
through the website contact form at
david pakman.com tell me if you will buy
one I don't need you to email me to tell
me you will not buy one because all that
matters is how many people will buy one
instead of doing this thing we sometimes
do of do you want us to make one or not
it really just comes down to we have a
limited amount of time and always many
many options for things that we can do
to engage with the audience if we
can't sell at least a few hundred of
these it probably doesn't make sense to
do it given the time and cost and
everything that goes into it so just get
in touch whether you are or aren't a
member if you would buy just a calendar
or sign up for a yearly membership to
get the calendar for free or you're
already a member but you would like
reappear yearly membership to get a
calendar let me know david pakman.com
the contact form is the way to do it and
I look forward to hearing from you and
more information soon if we are going to
do it we probably need to get Matt going
on the art like in the next week or so
so that he'll have time and then we can
get the calendar to print and get them
out to people before probably the end of
December a break so that's the plan if
we do it
get in touch david pakman.com I do want
to hear from you about this will you buy
a twenty twenty david pakman show
calendar let me know